[Music]
oh hi there you just caught me doing
some grip training so today i'm going to
be doing something a little bit
different today
i'm going to be reading from my new book
functional training
and beyond which is now available pretty
much everywhere in the world although
stock is in short supply in some places
i think on amazon if you're in the uk
you might have to wait a couple of weeks
for it to be delivered
but everybody else should have no
problem you can also buy lots of other
places like smith's
like water stones etc so yeah you can
find it i'll put some links in the
description down below
the book is basically a discussion about
functional training and why
all of us i think could benefit from a
more cross-modal approach to training
that focuses
not just on big lifts or just on cardio
and losing weight but rather on
improving our performance in every
different aspect that's available to us
and so it's a kind of discussion around
that of philosophy as well as
providing lots of hopefully actionable
tips that you can apply to your own
training
today i'm going to be reading a section
about fascia muscle fascia i mentioned
it in so many videos it's become
something of a
running joke but that's because fascia
is fascinating fascinating as i've
already joked in the past
and it applies to almost everything we
don't know that much about it it's this
film wrap that surrounds the muscle and
all the organs and just everything
and it has a lot more properties that
we're discovering all the time which may
or may not impact on our training but
anyways
get comfortable make a cup of tea and
i'll read you a section from my book and
if you enjoy this
this is the kind of thing you can expect
from the book so
check it out the evolution of movement
barefoot training the tarahumara tribe
cover a lot of different stuff in this
book natural human mobility the resting
squat
here we are training the fascia to me
the true aim of a fully functional
compound training program
should be to move the body as though it
were one muscle
that means using every part of the body
in unison towards
one biomechanical goal well guess what
this conceptualization
may be more literally accurate than you
previously imagined
while we have separate muscles they are
in fact contained by a single connective
sheet called muscle fascia or myofascia
this is just one form of the fascia that
is found throughout the entire body
if you have ever prepared a joint of
meat and notice that it's covered in a
thin
film well that right there is the fascia
this shrink wrap
was disregarded by fitness and medical
experts for hundreds of years
thought of as just some inert stuff in
fact it was rarely seen at all
seeing as the fascia is largely made up
of water and practically disappears
when the body is dissected that didn't
fool da vinci though
who actually included fascia in his
anatomical sketches
an elastic sheet of connective tissue
made from collagen the role of fascia is
to enclose and support
muscles and organs within their cavities
along with the bones
cells and practically everything else it
doesn't just fit around the outside of
the body like a catsuit
it actually weaves in and out of and
around muscles organs and cells even
morphing into
distinct elements like tendons and
aponeurosis
this viscous membrane network provides
tension throughout the entire body
that helps to keep everything in place
this property defines it as a tensegrity
structure
which also applies to the body at large
think about the way that a tent holds
itself up by maintaining constant
opposing tensions
this design may also allow the fascia to
dissipate impacts and energy across the
entire surface
thereby minimizing the damage caused by
a fall or other impact
the flexibility of the fascia therefore
contributes greatly to the flexibility
of an individual
as a whole with tightness in one area
affecting far flung parts of the body
but that's not all the muscle fascia
contains a large amount of elastin fiber
to help provide elasticity and can
actually supply additional
energy rebound when running or jumping
what is truly remarkable
is that the muscle fascia contains blood
vessels smooth muscle cells and even
sensory receptors
in fact fascia may be equal or even
superior
to the retina in terms of sensory nerve
receptor density
much of this information by the way
comes from anatomy trains
by tom myers it has between six to ten
times more nerve endings than muscle
in short it seems that the fascia may
play a key role
in the expression of strength along with
improved balance and agility
one of the important ways this happens
is via fascial force
transmission it appears that fascia
facilitates communication
between distant muscle groups such that
contracting one area
encourages another to contract two
what's more training seems to alter this
force transmission
fibroblast cells act like architects
traveling through the fascial system
and producing the necessary collagen
collagenase
which breaks down collagen and other
chemicals to help build and reform the
fascia
according to tom meyers this process
allows the fascia to strengthen itself
in response to specific areas of stress
and pressure signals
in other words the fascia can get
stronger across specific lines
to connect muscles that are often used
in tandem
it is also thought that an additional
function of the muscle fascia may be to
act as a kind of communication system
helping electrical signals to spread
between muscle groups
and nerve endings this could even go
some way to explaining the irradiation
effect
the fact that consciously contracting
one muscle tends to result in the
reactive tension of surrounding muscle
although that could also be due to the
close proximity and interlinking between
neural maps in the brain
the fascia might in fact be one of the
oldest features of the human body
allowing us to move and evade predation
even before we possess the nervous
system we're only just beginning to
scratch the surface of the muscle fascia
and what it is capable of we simply
don't know enough for me to provide
practical advice on how to train the
fascia as it were
right now whatever the case what
everyone can agree on is that the fascia
responds extremely well
to training with a wide variety of
different movements
the more you move the more pliable and
flexible the fascia will be
and the less tension you'll carry and
the greater control you'll have
over the entire body the fascia works
best when hydrated
which keeps it spongy and resilient
continually moving it in different
directions
seems to facilitate this suppleness
whereas a lack of movement may cause it
to become
rigid dehydrated and stiff likewise
moving in multiple vectors
meaning directions can potentially train
and strengthen this tissue in
angles that aren't described in the
traditional muscle tendon unit
model of human anatomy we must train the
entire system not just
individual muscles the fascia is
everywhere after all and we can move in
ways that our fixed muscle tendon units
cannot
if you remain in a purely fixed movement
pattern like
curling and squatting then the
surrounding fascia will be extremely
underdeveloped
compared to the fascia that sits right
next to it it's not a huge leap to
suggest
this may lead to discomfort and limited
strength development
in fascia training a whole system
approach authors bill parisi and
jonathan allen
even suggest that fascia training may be
partly responsible for
the farmer strength that we've
encountered previously farmers are
strong from labor work
because they have strengthened the
connective tissue at angles that are
otherwise ignored
through sub-maximal loads and with
non-repetitive movements
likewise the fascia will thank you for
performing each pull-up differently
movement training that takes you through
countless unpredictable movement
patterns
is ideal for fascia training if research
into fascia continues down this
promising path
it is very likely to offer increasing
support for these less rigid forms of
training
finally the fascia shows us just once
again how truly remarkable
and adaptable the human body really is
training with specific movements may do
more than just build the necessary
muscles
it may actually strengthen the tissue
between those muscles and help them to
work better together
as tom myers puts it the body responds
to demand
moving moving stuff so yeah if you
enjoyed that guys and you'll definitely
enjoy this book
i discuss everything from fascia to
movement training to calisthenics to
parkour to martial arts to old-time
strongmen power lifting bodybuilding
the golden era of bodybuilding i talk
about brain training cognitive training
anything that can offer some kind of
functional benefit and that is
so often missing or overlooked in our
training if you want a training program
based around these concepts with the
breakdown of different exercises etc and
even more information then you can also
find my ebook and training program
super functional training in the
description down below and there's a
discount on that right now
while so many people are stuck in
lockdown due to the pandemic
that being why my hair looks like this
so if you found this video useful
interesting guys if you did then please
leave a like and share it around
something a bit different today but i'll
be back to the usual programming
next week i've got some cool stuff on
the way including a goku workout parkour
training
why everybody should run and be
dexterity training so if that all sounds
good
then stay tuned please subscribe hit the
bell button for notifications
and thanks so much for your support
thanks for watching this one
and i'll see you next time bye for now